treatment for obesity lifestyle changes
if you're having trouble with obesity
lifestyle changes can help you lose
weight it's important to reduce your
energy in which is the amount of
calories in the food you eat and to
increase your energy out which is the
amount of calories your body burns
during physical activity
you can reduce the amount of extra
calories in your diet by making healthy
food choices such as fruits vegetables
whole grains and lean meats limiting
unhealthy snacks and desserts avoiding
high-calorie fast food by preparing food
at home instead eating smaller portion
sizes eating foods that are lower in fat
and reading food nutrition labels to
help you learn more about the foods
you're eating and make better choices
increasing your energy out through
physical activity can also help you lose
weight if you aren't used to exercising
start slowly with moderate intensity
activities over time you can move on to
more vigorous activities if you have any
questions about lifestyle changes to
treat obesity talk to your health care
provider